deben actuar ese fue el mensaje del
creciente de eeuu joe biden durante una
llamada telefónica a su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin en el centro de la
conversación los ciberataques
le dejé muy claro que eeuu se espera que
cuando las operaciones de rain software
vengan de su suelo aunque no estén
patrocinadas por el estado esperemos que
actúen si le damos suficiente
información que actúen sobre quién es
está
en los últimos meses de eeuu ha sido
blanco de varios ataques de 'hackers' la
empresa de software castilla ha sido la
última víctima la semana pasada sufrió
un ataque de ransomware como resultado
más de 1500 empresas se vieron afectadas
en mayo la compañía petrolera colonial
pipeline también fue atacada el ataque
de ransomware provocó escasez de
combustible en ese país
los ataques suelen ser llevados a cabo
por hackers rusos sin embargo moscú ha
negado toda responsabilidad la
ciberseguridad se ha convertido en la
última herida en las relaciones entre
eeuu y rusia durante su encuentro en
ginebra el pasado mes los dos jefes de
estado acordaron reunir expertos de
ambos países para resolver el problema a
principios de esta semana la casa blanca
dijo que estaba dispuesta a tomar
medidas si el gobierno ruso no puede o
no quiere tomar medidas contra los
actores criminales que residen en rusia
tomaremos medidas o nos reservaremos el
derecho de tomarlas por nuestra cuenta
el kremlin ha señalado de vuelta a eeuu
moscú dice que el gobierno de bailén
nunca le ha pedido ayuda para investigar
los recientes ataques pero washington lo
niega
que han enviado múltiples solicitudes